Identification. This is the second station with FAITH BANDLER and Carolyn Craig recorded on Friday.
Second of May one thousand nine hundred seven.
So this is tape two side one and the tape begins in ten seconds time and divide into sick ation.
Faith at the end of last session. You were telling me about your father's death.
And that there were those a funeral where many many many people came to the grave was deep in the grave digger is stood
with all our friends while my father's coffin was lowered into the grave. And.
The women in particular who had taken flowers from their own gardens great gardeners.
Now all and woman was without her flower garden. And you know the grave began to fill with flowers.
They threw the flowers on top of the coffin and read your. Purple those early years.
And quite daisies and cream roses and and these women stood around and just threw the flowers onto the coffin.
And then my brothers shovel it on the coffin because they wanted to do it and I know that normally the undertaker
or the grave diggers usually did that but let's step back with. The crowd and I can remember my brothers.
Trailing the gray with the red. And. My mother went around and said to everyone.
We're going now to Katie and Charlie's place and Katie and Charlie Charlie Charlie was my father's brother.
And Katie was his wife. And their house because.
It was about a mile and a half from the post-office and it was a hot place. It had three tanks.
And it was surrounded by a tree and mound retrace and from the bank a tree.
My uncle Charlie had begged water bags hanging. To cool the water for people to drink it and that my hot.
And although it was the month of July.
They'd been walking a long way to get to the few know many of them and then I had to now walk to Uncle Charlie and.
Auntie Katie's place. And it's true that.
The by the family who were smart history ten months or old myself and my other two sisters were put into care.
That was drawn by two horses was to three two. I think. And we were taken out in the cab.
So we were first there and Katie was in the cab as well. And when we got there. She. Sort of shook the coals.
Pre-heated the stoves again she had to use. Their caterers and Kate was for Coke.
And she had been brought from the island of Amber I'm a young girl of about eleven or twelve thing
and she was installed in this house and I and it was there she didn't learn
but she developed cooking skills because her mistress had no idea whatsoever.
And so she mastered the art of making brain and making batter. And just cooking. So it was wonderful.
Why she cooked for a couple of days. And there were poems of.
That are a wonderful gloss on them and she put a cross on it just for the fun. And beautiful scar.
And sponge cakes filled with Jerram and cream and then only other stuff and they opened fire
and there was an open fire in the lean to kitchen. Where she would buy to all the chooks.
And if she'd knocked off enough chooks to feed this mob.
And my brothers had gone they previously had not before and I knocked the trucks off and traced them. And as I said.
The big camper vans were full of chucks chairs huge pile of plates. He didn't eat of paper plates then and.
Roast potatoes roast pumpkin and big balls of. Just us wonderful lent to me you're. All of this was like a miracle.
To see you only food prepared. And. Matter and changed into matter happens for.
My oldest sister to help them and the boys. And the people began Torah. They arrived in this and.
There was no straight tension and they sat under the mango trees and under the Maori tree under the local tree.
And there were great big tables that had. Their legs were built into the earth and they were covered with long quite.
Cloths and these huge big so on and all of food was brought out and there was plenty for all plenty for all.
And so people cry and cry. And men were sitting in the streaming. Faces and. He was good to us too.
And the truth in fact was that no one could believe that him die because he was just always. Like a tree.
And he was always there to hunt for comfort and I wasn't there anymore and I think the way.
Brought about a fully realize Asian that he wasn't there and he wasn't going to be there any more.
And all the men sat there and I cried and I cried and cried and the remarkable thing was.
As I think of it today was that the word crash at all not even my mother.
They were too involved with the food in fact
and it wasn't really that I think it had to do with the fact that many of them had seen a lot of death.
They'd seen it on the cane fields before they scraped. They'd see in the black flag.
The children and and I with the characters. Made it worse it was somehow different.
And certainly my father had said he was always there. And I thought he'd always be there and he'd grow old with them.
And always be there. So in a sense a whole generation of islanders had really lent on him and relied on him.
The whole generation of islanders two generations in fact two generations because by now like him.
Many of them had grown up son. And I recall has a little woman. Who was a lawyer.
And perspire father and she married a man by the name of an island man who didn't come from the same.
As my father but my father and he were friends and they were married and you see they had thirteen children.
So it was another generation as well. Two generations. So the weeping winter and for a long time.
The men just sat in some set in a circle. And it stopped and it seemed to all. Stop it for us..
I said a lot of A had been clear. And there was an acceptance. And then when the T.K.
In my auntie Kate's Royal Albert and nothing less. I can tell you. And I asked for mags.
My mother and sister were brought big money they wanted mine
but all the women used the Royal Albert had written roses on it was a kind of Riccio saying for me to capture that.
But the main began to sing and I was sitting on.
Those who sat on the pile and boxes began to play time we think fingers fingers from hard work.
And I was beating time and it was just like the drug of the. You know it was discipline that.
The sea was pounding the rocks. And the beating just sort of the background and it was truly a very genuine farewell.
And after that. But that would on for court quite some time. Then they began to sing.
And they sang in many languages and that was the extraordinary thing about it.
When they came into Queensland the Queensland government called them or connect us.
And that is a whole way in which just means man and it was a city where they were thrown into a melting pot.
But they knew the differences and they retained their cultures. They remember their songs remember. The steps of the.
And they were on different. And the men who were there came from the island of Pentecost. Amber. And others.
And when they were singing. They each island group would have their own songs in their own language.
So at the same time you had these many languages
and the various songs coming from each little group that said under the mango tree or the mulberry tree. So.
After the singing.
And some danced on the earth and if it made a sound like that they took their shoes off and they danced.
And there was a period of Reacher we seen. He's got we've accepted this we have to get on with life and that it.
And all of this when you're only about five. Now I I was six or six. Yes and it's quite vivid. So. The white.
And pads in it was very late afternoon and the shadows were beginning to lengthen.
And I and he Katie set off to feed the chokes she used to feed them in the paddock. You know.
They were all free range of course free running and then she'd lock that she locked them up.
And that was over when a person did it it was time for the visitors to go.
I mean I've seen people in Sydney has given us all of info and we've set up. To go by getting at a vacuum cleaner.
But here we call the chooks.
And they were put on their coats and set off and many of those women walked a good ten miles.
They let evening they had ten miles ahead of them to walk back again for a walk or so. And we focus.
Stayed with that night with Auntie Katie Nicholl Chiles it was a very old rambling us.
There was masses of room and I don't think Katie rather enjoyed it because it was a time
when she could show off her fine linen.
And fine it was you know and she backed up the bids with these beautiful sheets.
And we went back to temple Holcombe the next day and we were in Paris.
And we had a pair and the camp took us from the house to the wharf. At No one umbrella and we got on the steamer.
And set off for Tom Bogan I really loved those trips in that Stamer it.
The boat service was owned by a very old mole and Baradei tittie by the name of movie. Skinner.
And he and I think about two or three is the vessels that took people down the tree drifted.
To and it stopped at Balcombe. Then I had another stop at children. And they went on to trade.
And what I'll have to about it if you went down in the morning with a. Ham sandwiches and tea.
That a woman attendant on the boat would make and make sure.
Now the kind of tea you get in restaurants here and I will bags. You have the genuine thing.
Beautiful horse bread with batter and. Mustard. And so my mother was taken care of great tender care by this woman.
And I remember her mother with her lovely black dress
and she wasn't crying somehow she would accept the fact that she was now and must have been a terrible blow to.
A dreadful. Because she had a baby that was only ten months. And. I can remember her saying the woman who served it.
Asking my mother when you have a tissue always have at Mrs massing his place and it would have a lovely. Creamy milk.
Lasts and strong. So we went back to our house in. And it seemed awfully lonely and empty to me.
And I couldn't remember feeling terribly terribly. That no longer would my father come and go from here.
Longer would he tell the story. Around the fire and no longer would he take me up to the.
There was a terrible emptiness. So many. And it was a great lesson for me. In fact it.
It made me fully realize how important both parents to a child.
And I've often thought since that when I've seen marriages break up. And the husband goes off or the wife.
And I have said to me so many of them. Look we fought so much.
It wasn't her staying together anymore but they've never ever said how it would affect the children.
And I think of who were next door but no longer. And when their marriage broke up. It also broke their office.
And to this day and that happened about ten twelve years ago to do this very day she has never forgiven the parents.
So you know I I know that children's loyalty is very divided and they really love the father
and they left the mother but they separate they keep it separate.
And this affected me very natural child and I experienced a sense of security after my father had gone.
And so on till eldest brother Jerome. Virtually sat in my father's place at the head of the table.
Could you just fill in a little bit about your siblings and the age range so that it paints a bit of a picture that.
John was when my father died he was nineteen and he was a very very responsible person very responsible
and it almost seemed to me years later that he. Rather enjoyed that new role of power. He actually controlled us kids.
What to do as he said. And then you see when father died two of my siblings.
Left her packed up and I went and lived with Child child Samantha character and one was my brother.
Eddie who was the second eldest and of and my sister Kate who was the second eldest.
And so they would pack their cases and they were taken to live. And go child. Kate.
Now Uncle Charles and Kate had a lot of money.
Because I was very careful and they'd served over the years
and those days it paid to say because money was really worth something and they were very generous to my brother
and narcistic they bought them bikes which we. And Kate had lovely dresses.
And they stayed at school my brother anywhere in town to high school for about two or three years
and that was really something.
And he enjoyed being the sister Kate was dreadfully homesick terribly sick
and after a short while she came back to the family in fact and brought all her dresses which we all know.
But and thereafter. Eddie who were second eldest there was my brother Tom.
Tom was an extraordinary he was taller in the family. He was six foot three six four I think. Straight as a telephone.
And he was a bit of a loner. He was a great reader.
A great reader if you'd read all the newspapers around the place and all the books you'd go
and look at a bit of brown paper sigs Those anything written or not. And after him came member of the.
Who with him mother wanted to christen well and it didn't work and he was a bold and reckless one of the family.
Had a will of the refused to go to school.
Just refused he well acted so often and wasn't funny and he was very very anxious and keen to earn money.
So very tender age he left her and he went away and he lived with and I. Was very good to him. And so.
He was like one of the family with him but the reason was and he was only eleven and when he did that
and the reason why I did it he wanted the use of the horses.
He was one who under four horsemen so wonderful that he could make the horses do anything
and he broke horses in for the families also.
And he'd sit on a horse and you look at him and you'd think born in the saddle. And so he came he left.
My mother didn't worry about him because she knew very good.
Because she knew all of these neighbors so well they went to each other's place for afternoon tea.
And there was no problem. In fact what strikes me is that you had this novice mixed community and know no difficulties.
Exactly. We didn't know what we do. Experienced any racial discrimination at all at all as young children.
And we had all of these Irish Catholic families around us and they'd come for afternoon tea
and mother would go to their place for afternoon tea and the crockery would improve their white tablecloth.
The whole works and that was always a lot about hearing.
We'd give them fruit and I'd give us pickles or something like that. It was a lot of exchange.
So my brother water went off and he worked with this family. And then that was Jesse the eldest girl.
And she was always a bit strange quite strange.
She never fitted in with the family she had terrible psychological problems
but the interesting thing about it is that she's outlived the whole lot of them except Nicky Butt
and then after that of course was Kate. Who was worse and so.
But she cared about her so she brushed sometimes she just found sitting around the house just brushing her hair.
And she too was a great reader were always begging for books we never had unless. There are now.
And caves wasn't a great reader.
She was more of a sports person she always won the races at school
or was highly intelligent she what she was very good at dictation. If we couldn't.
Couldn't reach for the dictionary would shout. How do you spell so and so you know.
How do you spell this how do you spell that but use awful awful at math.
You know there was an exam one day and she got everyone have a semester off and then of course it was me
and youngest sister Marie who was ten months old. And they were. This is terrific really terrific family.
I can look back on it now and see the good things.
Certainly there were times as a child when I wished that we have a piano
and a violin which you could never have afforded but lets her it was but we had all of this wonderful companionship
and to quite an extent everyone looking after each other.
Did you have a favorite sibling when you were a girl oh yes that you know big families do tend to pair off. And.
It's true to say that Walter and Kate were the three of us were might.
And we were very close didn't have a favorite didn't. Well John like to saw he feel that role magnificently is a far.
And he took over all the cooking from my mother. And my mother wasn't much of a cook. You know.
She just couldn't be bothered to choose or rather sit around the place and so.
But when John took over the cook all the shopping and the cooking. And we did he did the shopping by ballot.
We had a head about it and it was always sort of what's the word you don't.
Park about two more in the local creek and down into the. Paddle right in the valley and they have more the boat again.
At the local store fill it up with the bags of sugar and bags of flour. Well there were a lot to feed you.
And take it back. I mean we didn't have to buy jam because that was made. A lot was made.
Certainly but we needed fifty pounds of flour each time for the bread making. And so he do all of that take it.
And do you know why. And he would go to the local slaughterhouse stated they knew.
Instead of the butcher and he'd get the made for pittance. So wonderful or huge field with vegetables from.
There because he'd always. Slip up. Today I haven't. And we had pie dishes that would feed this big family.
They were huge. So he'd make. Rice custard Brydon that are custard on the top of the bread and butter custard.
And then put them on the top and then when we'd have it he'd pull the cream just. Just.